the American elites this goes back to
the constitutional convention have been
very concerned that over what's
sometimes called an excess of democracy
that is real participation by the public
in formulating policy in fact the
constitutional system was designed to
prevent that
Madison's conception was that what he
called the wealth of the nation that the
responsible set of men they're the ones
who should set policy that's why the
Senate which represented the wealthy was
given most of the power in the
constitutional system least responsive
to the public more consisting of wealth
and there's have been battles about this
all through American history and of
course things have changed a lot since
the Constitutional Convention but the
basic theme remains the same so for
example the leading public intellectual
the 20th century walter Lippmann
progressive Wilson Roosevelt Kennedy
progressive his view he wrote were
called progressive essays on democracy
very influential in his view was that
the public should be spectators not
participants and that the what he called
the responsible people people like him
the ones that make policy they should be
insulated from the public as he put it
they ought to be protected from the
trampling and the roar of the bewildered
herd the general public ignorant and
meddlesome outsiders who don't belong in
the political system that's a very
standard view I mean this is a version
from you know the progressive sector but
it extends pretty much across the
spectrum that's why after the there was
an outburst of Democratic participation
in the 1960s infected significantly
civilized the Society but it caused
enormous concern among elites there was
a major study
called the crisis of democracy by
relatively liberal elites basically for
example the Carter Administration was
drawn from their ranks that sector
internationally and they were concerned
about the excess of democracy too much
participation
that's an overload on the state you
can't have all these so-called special
interest pressing their own demands who
are the special interests of minorities
women the young the old farmers workers
in fact the population they're the
special interests then there's the
national interest which has to be
sustained and that's the interest of the
one sector that they don't mention
namely concentrated private capital
which is overwhelming in its influence
but they represent the national interest
so it's okay in fact you know Madison
had rather similar ideas that's a
leading conception of social and
political thought and there's a lot of
effort put into instigating it that's
what propaganda is about we don't call
it propaganda but what appears in you
know the media and the schools and so on
and you can see its fact